bonjour bienvenue allison merci alors
allison on est ravis de vous accueillir
pour cette ce format tedx un petit peu
modifié on est toujours adaptée aux
changements bien bien entendu parce que
c'est plus convivial parce que c'est
plus rassurant parce que c'est plus tout
simplement bah ouais innovants on
pourrait dire allison cavaillé
expliquez-nous qui êtes vous
bonjour à tous et à toutes m'appelle
aysan cavaillé j'ai 33 ans et je suis la
fondatrice d'une marque de vêtements
d'allaitement qui s'appelle tajine banal
que j'ai cofondé avec mon frère et mon
conjoint en othe 2018 pourquoi pourquoi
tu as créé du coup cette marque qu'est
ce qui a poussé cette envie et qu'est ce
que c'est aussi une banane du coup
jean banane c'est
c'est ce sont des vêtements la
spécificité classiques sont des
vêtements qui sauvent sur les côtés avec
des iep ou dépression et qui permettent
en fait à la mamans allaitantes de
pouvoir allaiter partout tout le temps
comme elles le veulent et ans habillée
dans son dressing habituel donc ça c'est
vraiment le
vraiment le bea va de la marque c'est ça
et du coup d'août est venue cette idée
justement d'aller sur les les je veux
dire les fringues des vêtements d audrey
oui friendly ça se dit tout simplement
parce que j'en ai eu besoin donc moi
j'ai trois enfants j'ai allaité
les deux premiers plus ou moins
longtemps voilà j'ai eu une expérience
d'allaitement j'ai découvert le fait
d'allaiter en plein été ou en plein
hiver quand on allaite un enfant on sait
pas quand même biberon pour celles et
ceux qui ne savent pas il n'y a pas
vraiment de régularité fond m st et
parfois c'est plusieurs fois dans la
journée donc à partir du moment où on
passe sa journée à relever son tee shirt
son pull et c'est ça devient un peu
compliqué donc on se rend compte qu'on
tourne toujours avec les mêmes fringues
et comporte toujours les mêmes choses et
des choses enfin des freins qui sont
pratiques à la naissance du troisième
moi j'ai une grossesse en bref assez
compliqué j'ai fait des grosses
complications au moment de
l'accouchement donc quand je suis sorti
de l'hôpital j'ai eu j'avais des
pansements sur le ventre et on était en
plein hiver donc un petit peu difficile
de m'imaginer lever mon pull comme je
l'avais fait pour la ses frères et
soeurs et là ce que j'ai fait à ce
moment là c'est que j'ai pris un t-shirt
à mon mec et j'ai mis deux coups de
ciseaux j'ai pris un gros gilet et en
fait j'ai allaité avec un tee shirt
troué toujours le même mais c'était mon
t-shirt et au bout d'une semaine deux
semaines trois semaines je me suis dit
quand même c'est fou que ce soit sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que j'étais déjà à
l'époque assez friands des réseaux
sociaux même si je n'avais pas du tout
comment ni rien du tout et je me suis
dit c'est fou on parle beaucoup de mères
on parle beaucoup de maternité on
commence un peu à libérer la parole mais
personne ou très peu de gens parlent de
l'allaitement alors que ça concerne
énormément de femmes je me sentais pas
représentés ni vos fringues c'était
catastrophique donc je me suis dit bon
ces t-shirts dans lesquelles j'ai fait
des trous serait peut-être cool d'en
faire quelque chose d'un peu moins moche
un petit peu plus travaillé et là j'ai
fait appel à une couturière et samassa
m'a coûté les yeux de la tête parce que
je savais pas coudre donc ça a pris du
temps et quand ce proto est arrivé mais
je me suis retrouvé avec un t-shirt qui
coûtait 1000 balles puis je me suis dit
beige peut-être cesser de me rembourser
au moins cet argent là et j'ai cherché
une usine et et j'en ai trouvé une au
portugal et cette usine m'a dit ok on te
fais ton t-shirt le parc quand on fait
deux cents et là c'était un peu le début
du hold up de ce changement de vie dans
le sens où avec ses 2 100 t-shirts
qui sont qui ont débarqué un matin d'été
dans mon salon je me suis retrouvé avec
plein de cartons et la jsio qu'il je
suis dans la merde va falloir vraiment
dans la crotte il va falloir vraiment
que je fasse quelque chose de ces
t-shirts et j'ai créé un compte
instagram qui s'appelle tajine banane
qui au début le surnom de ma famille en
me disant ben là au moins je vais
pouvoir un peu communiquer dessus et
essayer de refourguer cette magnifique
idée plus de monde possible et très
rapidement et ça c'est fait ça s'est
lancé comme ça et qui s'appelle royo
l'entrepreneuriat quelque part où on
parlait d' aventure en phase
préparatoire en quoi c'est devenu une
aventure en fête a commencé en mode
start up garage et à aller dans l'est
dans les hautes sphères comme hbo comme
on peut le voir à l'image que tu nous
raconter un petit peu après les 200
maquettes dans le salon voilà qu'on peut
voir ici qu'est ce qui s'est passé ou
est-ce que vous en êtes aujourd'hui
donc on a commencé dans du coup je vais
piquer ses tee shirts à ses specs on a
commencé dans le garage donc à la
rochelle en famille donc avec macky mon
conjoint qui vont tout de suite
rejoindre l'aventuré à partir d'un
moment j'ai commencé à danser les
t-shirts sur les réseaux sociaux ils se
seront éventuellement vite que tous on
m'a dit ok on ne peut pas te laisser
tout seul là dedans on vient avec toi et
de caunes est passé du garage à une un
espace de plus de 200 mètres carrés dans
le bordeaux aujourd'hui qu' un autre
bureau et notre boutique
là on est passé de 3 22 salariés et on
est passé de 5000 euros d'investissement
à plusieurs millions de chiffre
d'affaires en trois ans
bon je pense qu'on peut applaudir quand
même c'est pas bon
et alors ce problème commence le disais
c'est comme on dit souvent start up il
faut plutôt que trouver des solutions il
faut plutôt trouver des problèmes à
résoudre avec une solution tu l'a
ressenti en étant toi même maman en
ayant ce besoin d'allaiter du coup peux
tu nous parler de ton parcours plus
globalement
oui
c'est ce qui ce qui a fait que ça a été
difficile d'accepter cette invitation
parce que le syndrome de l'imposteur
tout ça tout ça
moi j'ai été maman très tôt j'ai été
maman mon premier garçon à 18 ans donc à
18 ans quand on est maman mais c'est
souvent la galère faut dire les mots et
ça l'a été pour moi si bien que ça a
signé la fin mon parcours scolaire
puisque j'ai décidé d'abandonner l'école
quelques mois avant le bac donc j'ai
quitté l'école quelques quelques années
plus tard j'ai eu la chance d'avoir sa
petite soeur mais on était toujours dans
la galère j'ai connu tous les petits
jobs casquette frites et compagnie et
quelques voilà j'ai fait mon parcours
comme ça j'ai fait une école
d'aide-soignante parce que j'avais
besoin d'aider les autres
c'est est ce qu'il est et ce kit ça se
voit c'était ce qui me c'était ce qui me
motivait est en fait grâce à cette école
des soignants je me suis totalement
épanouie j'ai fait ça pendant quelques
années jusqu'à ce que j'aie mon
troisième enfant et que soit en congé
maternité et que je crée tajine banal
donc ça n'a strictement aucun sens donc
pour toutes les personnes qui se posent
des questions j'ai entendu charlotte
tout à l'heure sur les trous dans leur
cv et compagnie il vous trouve dans le
cv j'ai quelques quelques notions donc
on arrive toujours en fait à puiser de
nos expériences professionnelles
des enseignements et particulièrement
par exemple dans l'école des sciences
que ce qui m'a
une des clés qui que je retiens le plus
de cette profession c'est l'art de
communiquer même si aujourd'hui je
stressais dans son sens quand on
communique avec des patients communique
avec
des personnes avec des femmes des hommes
des personnes âgées des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité
des gens malades des gens m'ont rend
donc à partir du moment où tu arrives
avec le ton de ta voix des gestes et
l'allemagne jusqu'à la manière injuste
avec toi même à rentrer en contact avec
des personnes dans ces situations
difficiles henri tu peux communiquer
avec tout et ça je m'en suis rendu
compte parce que mais en ayant la marque
j'ai créé ce fameux conte installe
dans mon lit sans aucune notion sur mon
compte perso j'avais à peine 200 abonnés
dont quand on a 200 abonnés on les
connaît sur nos amis ce sont des gens
qu'on sait très bien qui sait et du jour
au lendemain j'ai créé ce compte et sans
aucune publicité sans rien du tout on
est passé de zéro à cent soixante trois
mille abonnés est ce que ça veut dire
par là derrière ces chiffres c'est que
on a réussi à fédérer une communauté et
pour fédérer une communauté je pense
qu'il faut parler vrai et je pense très
sincèrement
mais juste mon taf défaillante qui m'a
appris à parler vrai en quoi une
reconversion un trou dans le cv ça et
d'eau aux changements à faire quelque
chose qui nous correspond plus c'est une
période qui t'a permis de changer
d'évoluer en fait un petit apprend
énormément et apprend énormément sur toi
même et en fait tu te rends compte que
de toutes les périodes de tous ces trous
de cv et il y en a un autre qui est
assez énorme dans un trou de cv en
général dans la vie d'une femme c'est la
maternité
quand on dit congé maternité ça n'a rien
de congé est en fait tout ce temps qu'on
passe avec nos enfants c'est du temps
qui tu apprends à gérer des conflits qui
tu apprends à gérer des budgets qui
tapera pas dormir à pas contés teaser a
donné sans compter je pense que si juste
exactement la même chose qu'on dit quand
on est entrepreneur donc finalement
avoir eu trois enfants d'avoir fait
cette école est d'être entre guillemets
bananas en bacs
mais tout ce que tu apprends sur le bas
dans l'école de la vie tu le jeu arrive
après l'entrepreneuriat c'est
tout et c'est fluide finalement le
syndrome de l'imposteur il n'y a plus
trop lieu d'être finalement ça ils
aiment bien là
ça j'ai pas encore trouvé la clé et
baisse et je n'étais pas enchaîner avec
cette sly 2 justement cesser enfin voila
c'est quand même assez beau de partir de
peut-être que situation personnelle
chaotique aussi si tu tu me permet
l'usagé de ce mot arrivé voilà une belle
équipe souriante comme ça moi j'aimerais
bien tous les noms et prénoms là tout de
suite de tout le monde c'est vrai on je
rigole je
ne connais pas
je les aime beaucoup
social oui c'est chouette est-ce que ça
t'inspire de douala de voir ce à quoi
la petite fille j'allais dire de 17 ans
qui apprend qu'elle est enceinte qui
voient ça maintenant qu'est-ce que ça
t'inspire
et c'est pour toutes les jeunes filles
comme moi que je force parce que même si
je prends du plaisir avec vous j'en
prends pas de ouf double sens où c'est
compliqué pour moi
que je me force à venir là parce que je
pense que comme tout à chacun on a
besoin de role models on a besoin de
montrer qu'il existe différents parcours
qu'il existe différents chemins et que
s'il ya certaines personnes qui sont
motivés par les millions et mais tant
mieux dans mon discours si elle a
d'autres qui sont motivés par le fait de
pas avoir son bac es bête en milieu et
en fait je me dis que il n'ya pas de n'y
a pas de route tracée et qu à mon avis
si on m'avait si j'avais entendu des
matches comment à l'époque je me serais
senti beaucoup moins mal à l'aise ne pas
avoir de bach se serait senti beaucoup
moins
inutile plein
je voulais partait parler aussi du
management en voyant l'équipe toutes ces
aventures de vie la maternité
l'improvisation enfin tout ce que tu
nous racontes si tu lisais que ça tu
avais et des ajustements
et des a managé par la vie parce que 22
personnes passé le 3 22 personnes c'est
ce qu'on appelle une grosse croissance
quand start up est le principal risque
c'est de ne pas s'entendre de
s'engueuler avec les zones non qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que ça t'a appris justement ça
mais ça arrive je suis déjà je me suis
déjà il ya eu des échecs de co2
de recrutement il ya eu il ya eu déjà eu
je pense à une fille qui parti et qui ne
s'est pas senti bien dans la botte et
c'était notre première recrue ça veut
pas rien dire tu te remets en question
en fait tu te remets en question même
quand tes parents tu te remets en
question dont on coupe tout remis en
question tout le temps et je crois que
tout avis peux tu apprendras être le
manager de demain et a pas forcément
besoin d'eux à partir du moment où tu
t'entends
tentons tous les chèques tu acceptes et
tu te remets en question tu veux je sais
pas tu évolues et puis après il faut
être il faut être moi je ne me considère
pas comme une chef d'entreprise en sens
où quand je leur parle je leur parle pas
en prenant pour quelqu'un d'autre dans
le sens où elles savent très bien que
j'ai pas justement ce bagage que moi mon
premier de l'épreuve la première fois
que j'ai mis les pieds dans un bureau
mais c'était dans le mien donc à partir
de ce moment là j'ai beaucoup moins
d'expérience qu'elle que toutes les
personnes que je recrute aujourd'hui et
ça dès l'entretien le savent ils le
savent il ya un mec le port est donc en
fait ça permet de garder des relations
hyper hyper direct parce que tout s'est
tous bien et je crois qu'il ya aussi une
affaire d'engagement derrière tajine
banal ou d'engagement personnel peut
être aussi une entreprise est ce que tu
peux nous en parler
parce que comme je l'avais dit outre le
fait d'avoir eu un besoin
pratico-pratique de vêtements je me
sentais pas représenté et comme toutes
les personnes toutes les minorités qui
sont qui ne se sentent pas représentés
par don en général on va chercher soi a
trouvé le rôle modèle soit entre
guillemets j'ai pas la prétention de le
dire mais à a créé ce dont on m'a manqué
et
et ce qui se passe avec l'allaitement
maternel et c'est pas un exotique
malheureusement il existe encore et
surtout en france parce qu'il vend
certains pays ça va mieux
des femmes qui sont littéralement
agressé parce qu'elles allaitent dans
l'espace public donc je pense que cette
année on y voit que tu as dit et on en a
eu quelques-uns qui sont des articles
qui sont sortis je sais pas si vous les
avez vus mais il y en a je pensais au
moins à 3 donc je
parle du postulat que mon vêtement
finalement il devenu un vecteur
et grâce à va dire aux tee-shirts grâce
à la fringue je peux défendre le droit
d'allaiter partout tout le temps et
c'est ce qui fait la force au 6 de la
marque et du coût de l'engagement de la
communauté c'est parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'il ya un problème et le
problème il est pas juste je sais pas
comment m'habiller c'est derrière il ya
énormément de 2,2 de problèmes qui sont
sous-jacents comme le congé maternité
comme beaucoup beaucoup de choses qu'il
va falloir un petit peu repensé et c'est
vrai que grâce à tâche d'une banale je
pense par exemple ya quelques semaines
j'étais au ministère de l'intérieur avec
marlène schiappa pour parler de du
projet de loi sur
la pénalisation en fait justement du
délit d'entravé à l'allaitement qui va
ça paraît un peu improbable qu'on en
arrive là mais en gros jusqu'à présent
si je suis en train d'allaiter tu peux
me dire arrête de faire ce que tu fais
tu as le droit donc voilà il ya plein de
choses qui se passent et je le sers je
me sert concrètement de ma phrase pour
pouvoir aller plus loin derrière ce qui
parle aussi aux salariés c'est important
de ne pas faire des fringues allaitement
pour faire des fringues d'allaitement
c'est aussi des freins des vêtements
pour le changement le changement de
société c'est une des premières choses
que qu'en général les gens nous disent
on entretient souvent les filles qui
postulent chez moi nous suivent ou
entendu parler nous ou même était
cliente arrive très souvent et c'est ce
qui motive en fait c'est ce qui motive à
avoir telle entreprise a mission tu sais
que tu fais du textile en plus le
textile on a parlé d'écologie on va
parler de pollution va pas revenir là
dessus mais sait pas où est du coup à
partir du moment où même mois la
première vue que ce n'est pas mon métier
j'ai jamais rêvé de ni d'avoir une boîte
mais je suis pas styliste c'est pas du
tout franchement mais je pense le nombre
de fois où je vais dans un magasin de
fringues parents ça se compte sur les
doigts d'une main
je suis pas du tout ce que je suis en
train de faire aujourd'hui je pense que
si j'avais pas un but et la latte motifs
derrière je n'en serais pas là en train
de discuter avec vous et les gens qui me
rejoignent c'est pareil en même temps
qui peut prédire l'avenir personne et
surtout pas un professeur de
mathématiques je crois pour cette
dernière cela y de conclusive oui très
fort
du coup oui quelle anecdote
quand j'avais quand j'avais 14 ans donc
j'étais dans mon j'étais au collège et
j'avais un petit copain qui s'appelait
nicolas est en fait nicolas la
récréation s'embrasser moment où on
s'embrasse juste derrière son dos genre
je vois mon prof de maths passé et moi
je vois que je le vois enfin tu moment
malesan et je me dis bon c'est pas grave
j'ai 14 ans hélas le cours d'après la
récréation c'est un cours de maths je
m'entends classe mon prof m'attend au
tournant me dit oui bon bec correction
du devoir tu pars au tableau sachant que
j'avais 2 de moyenne à l'époque en
mathématiques ton clairement tu sais
très bien que j'ai pas faire grand chose
dans la correction 6 né voilà humilier
un petit peu du coup je passe au tableau
les minutes sont très très très très
longue et bien sûr je donne aucune
réponse et une fois que la classe bien
foutu de moi et on dit c'est bon tu peux
retourner à ta place
là je marche au moment où je passe
devant lui il me dit tu sais où allison
je veux dire quelque chose sur les
filles comme toi ils finissent
là eu un blanc j'ai senti la patate je
lui dis non et la mdi sur un trottoir
est en fait par rapport à cette anecdote
ce qui était important pour moi de vous
dire
c'est qu'au fond les mecs n'avaient pas
tort parce que quelques années plus tard
et il ya quelques semaines gérer
réellement investi les trottoirs de
paris avec plus de 5000 affiches pour
protéger le droit d'allaiter partout
tout le temps
et la seule chose que j'avais envie de
pain de finir c'était simplement de vous
dire que quel que soit votre parcours
scolaire que vous soyez accusé bakupa
même si ici en a pas mal qui l'ont déjà
depuis longtemps
que vous soyez encore chez vos parents
que vous soyez vous mêmes parents je
vous souhaite mais concrètement de finir
votre vie ou si mal que moi sur un
trottoir à défendre ce qui est important
pour vous
[Applaudissements]